hey everybody let's talk about la Drive
you wanna know how you came into this
world guess how much this future cause
I'm a fan of lingerie I've never bought
any from anybody but someone has
surprised me with some and I had to say
very pleasant surprise I think when
girls wear lingerie it looks great I
think any type of lingerie is pretty
sexy I guess I'm a fan of it as much as
I'm offended with one direction
essentially okay okay so this is a one
this I think it's a holdup it literally
looks like a baby could fit wow they
just straight-up made a butthole on this
like what are we doing not much material
you're seeing everything so that's my
point of the worthlessness of it it's
like why weird I can see everything
already
the butthole thing that's gonna add
another 25 to it for sure I'm gonna just
go with a hundred dollars hundred
dollars for this one piece butthole i'ma
say fifty I'm gonna say fifty one
dollars forty dollars
that's a deal everybody needs one of
these is a cheap one yo it's the starter
package this is what it
this is wish you what you started evolve
something betted body by Victoria who is
Victoria and what is her seat this kind
of looks like a doily you know what a
doily is like your grandmother I hope my
grandma doesn't have this cut out for
Grandma I say forty for the whole thing
it's a need to I still say like 30 bucks
for both
I don't even think I'm wearing $70 right
now this is said this is hot too this
what I say I think the black makes it
like no see if she might mess around be
missing these with my short hair 35 $35
and I say 20 35 15 15 299 buy 299 that's
299 I don't know [ __ ] about lingerie we
got close once okay
Oh Agent Provocateur that green and
orange this is like Easter this is the
equivalent of like a visor you know like
like put it on like this is a hat but
not quite
I still want you to see my hair then why
are you wearing a hat I'm gonna say this
like 95 bucks 100 bucks maybe
i'ma say $14.99 I 10 $100 $80 $85 80 $85
tucking the side for what yeah I feel
like you should get a bottom pair for
this like you or you get two for the
price of what that's insane I just enjoy
conceptually that like you have socks as
a part of your lingerie you know I
didn't expect that to happen and I would
definitely buy that for me myself and I
to spend anything more on one like just
like on a two piece set that's more than
$75 to me is just it's insane I'm trying
to put it on the secondary market right
we're going into business back and kills
[Music]